why
so Civil War issue number seven brings
an end to the Maine Civil War conflict
that is to say these skirmishes and
battles that have been going on between
Captain America's forces and Iron Man's
forces and it does it in a way where we
basically see this sort of last-ditch
effort this sort of final battle at the
Alamo so to speak and as the comic opens
up we of course see that Captain America
shouts a signature phrase Avengers
Assemble and from this point until the
end of the conflict the battle will
basically be total pandemonium we see
that as these individuals are fighting
as Bishop is fighting vision as Captain
America is attempting to stop Bishop as
radioactive man is fighting hoechlin and
of course Iron Man is continuing his
attempt to thwart the efforts of Captain
America's forces net shield is
attempting to lock down the against the
teleportation field between Rikers
Island and the negative zone and that
this shutdown will commence in about
five seconds from here we transition to
T'Challa to black panther and dagger and
what we see is a black panther is
attempting to override the sequence that
shield has initiated but there's a sixty
nine digit code that he can't quite
remember from here of course we see that
spider-man is fighting against Iron Man
which is really sort of this I guess
event that's been building up we see
that for the most part I guess
spider-man's trying to get some
retribution for the previous conflict
that Iron Man and spider-man had
previously had but before spider-man is
able to launch a full-on strike against
Iron Man he is stopped by Lady
Deathstrike and venom from here we
switched to Maria Hill and one of her I
guess
shield operatives and this shield
operative is telling Maria Hill that
Black Panther is attempting to override
their sequence and that he's rerouting
the bridge to the Baxter building
we see that Maria Hill tells him that
this needs to be shut down and then we
see the black panther tells dagger that
that shield is onto them and that
they've got about ten seconds before
they close the portal to the Baxter
building we see that dagger calls on
cloak
tells cloak that he needs to initiate
the biggest teleport teleport these ever
initiated before that he effectively
needs to teleport everybody out of this
negative zone area and back to someplace
out in the open air back to earth we see
that cloak is a little hesitant about
this cloak isn't really sure if he wants
to do this because this will be the
biggest attempt and it may be something
that might kill him but dagger says that
if the if he doesn't do this that
they're all going to be stuck in the
negative zone and they'll all be
arrested and taken away by shield we see
that cloak is able to pull in everybody
who is fighting in the negative zone and
teleport them to Manhattan whether
dropped above the skies of the New York
City skyline we see the Captain America
calls on everybody both on iron man's
side and on his own side who is capable
of flight to catch those individuals who
would not be able to withstand the fall
to the streets of New York from here we
see that the fight the fight begins
again and that again the entire conflict
dissolves into total pandemonium we see
that Iron Man calls on various
street-level police and individuals to
try to clear the area of civilians and
of course we see that the fight
continues with Iron Man once again what
we also see is that as this conflict
continues we see that spider-man is
fighting various individuals he's
fighting Reed Richards he's fighting
people in such a way that it catches
Reed Richards by surprise just by his I
guess she rigidity and his ability to
dodge the I guess the stretching arms
the the attempts of Reed Richards to
ensnare spider-man what we also see is
that Captain America is locked in combat
with both Lady Deathstrike and venom in
addition to taskmaster and a couple
other people and for the most part
Captain America is highly out of class
by these individuals he's simply not
able to fight all four of them at one
time and when it appears that Lady
Deathstrike is prepared to deal the
killing blow that Captain America is
saved by the arrival of name of this
mariner and his Atlanteans from here the
fight begins again but then we see that
Ironman calls on his own reinforcements
who arrive in the form of Thor or the
cyborg version of Thor as well as all of
the on the other engineered superheroes
that were created by Reed Richards from
here again the fight continues and once
again I guess dissolves into total
pandemonium that it's total chaos in the
streets of Manhattan that there isn't a
whole lot that can be done by the police
or really anybody other than the
superheroes to attempt to end this
entire fight what we also see is that
Captain America and Tony Stark are
fighting each other once more which
again is a continuation of their fight
during at the chemical plant but vision
arise and is able to disable the armor
of Iron Man for a short amount of time
from here we see that Captain America
begins to absolutely pummel Tony Stark
the cyborg version of Thor attempts to
assist Ironman as he's being pummeled by
Captain America but then we see that
Hercules steps in and begins to fight
for in addition we see that Ben Grimm
arrives and Ben Grimm is able to I guess
assist the side of Captain America's
forces in their attempt to defeat the
forces of Iron Man and so what we see
here is that for the most part aside
from mutants that all hands are on deck
when it comes to this conflict and so
this is the reason why for the most part
the entire state of Manhattan or the
entire area of Manhattan isn't almost
total pandemonium we see that taskmaster
attempts to shoot Susan storm but
instead shoots Reed Richards
because Reed Richards had I guess jumped
in front of this killing blow in order
to ensure that Susan storm SATA stayed
safe in response to this Susan storm
absolutely crushes taskmaster using her
ability to create force fields and uses
it in an offensive way as opposed to a
defensive way from here we transition
back to Hercules and the cyborg version
of Thor and what we see is one of the
things that we previously talked about
where very few people are able to
actually wield the hammer
or and Hercules is one of those
individuals Hercules wielding the hammer
for is able to destroy the cyborg
version of Thor by smashing its head in
from here we switch back to Captain
America and Iron Man and Captain America
is continuing this relentless pummel of
Tony Stark we see that he's continuing
to absolutely thrash Tony Stark up and
down and it's a total reversal of the
conflict that we had seen when the two
of them had fought at the chemical plant
because during the chemical plant fight
we had seen that for the most part
Captain America was being absolutely
pummeled by by Tony Stark but in this
circumstance we see is the exact
opposite but then we see that various
individuals jump in and stop Captain
America and some of these individuals
are firefighters some of police
some are EMS and others are just random
civilians that don't want to see Captain
America stoop to this level as Captain
America is being held back by these
individuals he tells them to stop he
says that he doesn't want to hurt them
and then one of them says that it's a
little too late for that
from here we transition to the entire I
guess the entirety of the destruction
that has taken place in Manhattan and
that in this entire conflict in this
entire battle the I guess the end of
this war that's gone on that Manhattan
has been completely ravaged by this
conflict between these superheroes and
Captain America realizes this Captain
America tells his team that they're
wrong that Iron Man's forces are right
that they're not fighting for the people
anymore that they're simply just
fighting and Captain America lays down
his arms he effectively surrenders to
shield and this is a very important part
of the Civil War event one because of
course this is Captain America laying
down his arms and effectively giving up
which pretty much ends the entire
resistance for the most part as far as
Captain America leading it but what we
also see here is that to a degree
Captain America is coming to is tensed
but what we will see during civil war a
frontline issues number 10 and 11 is
that Captain America hasn't necessarily
come to an understand
in terms of realizing that he is 100%
wrong but what we see here is that with
Captain America surrendering that it's
not Captain America that's being
arrested that it's actually Steve Rogers
that's being arrested and Captain
America says this is a totally different
thing from here we transition to a
letter that is being written by Reed
Richards to Susan storm and he tell
Susan storm that it's been two weeks
since the battle took place and in
Manhattan and that in the wake of
Captain America's a surrender that
various individuals various heroes have
accepted amnesty that various heroes
have gone to shield and either
registered or asked to be exonerated of
their crimes by virtue of registering
what we also see here is that as as Reed
Richards is talking to Susan storm or I
guess writing this letter to Susan storm
he says that he felt it was appropriate
to discuss their future to discuss what
was going to go on with the two of them
and this is really an appeal by Reed
Richards to tell Susan storm just how
sorry he is that he feels as though he
has severely messed up that he had put
the wrong thing wrong things first we
see him talk about how the superhero
initiative has gone through that the
fifty state initiative is now in effect
meaning that there are superhero teams
in all 50 states we see him talking
about how some of these superheroes have
been individuals that were created
through the efforts of Reed Richards
Hank Pym and Tony Stark and that these
individuals are for the most part
reinstating or I guess bringing back
this faith that humanity has in
superheroes we see that the negative
zone which was a controversial prison
which had which had very harsh
conditions that it was met with applause
when people finally went public with it
when shield finally said that there is a
place where they are taking superheroes
who refused to register and it is
outside the planet Earth now this is a
very big thing here because what this
means is that Humanity is in effect
celebrating the idea that superheroes
who refused to register are basically
being exile
from the planet earth entirely what we
also see here is that of course there's
always going to be this sort of struggle
there's always going to be this attempt
to ensure that various superheroes who
have eluded shield but are still part of
the underground will eventually be
rounded up and they will eventually be
captured and they will eventually have
to stand for their actions of being
against the registration movement what
we also do is we switch to the shield
Helicarrier which of course houses the
shield headquarters above New York City
and we see that Tony Stark is speaking
with Miss Sharpe and if you recall our
discussions during the previous events
of civil war we had talked about how
miss Sharpe was one of the individuals
that had been a major proponent had been
a major supporter of the superhuman
Registration Act and we see that Tony
Stark has been appointed to the position
of Director of shield and that Maria
Hill has been demoted to the position of
deputy commander and in response to this
we see that as a bit of degradation or
maybe as a bit of us those of us who
read this comic or read the Civil War
series and hated Maria Hills so much
during these this series that she is
asked by Tony Stark
to fetch some coffee along with cream
and sugar for both Tony Stark and n miss
Sharpe from here we see that Tony Stark
is talking to miss sharp about this
entire Civil War movement this entire
war that's going on about how they have
effectively won and about how this fifty
state initiative and the thunderbolts
becoming part of the fifty state
initiative by virtue of operating out of
Colorado will begin to restore this
faith and superheroes that humanity had
for the most part previously lost and
that there will really always be this
sort of struggle there will really
always be this element of people who for
some reason will develop powers later on
and it may very well choose to become
super villains or may become super
heroes but choose not to register and
that as those events unfold as those
circumstances arise that shield will
deal with them and ultimately we begin
to see that this comic comes to an end
as Miss Sharpe tells Tony Stark that she
believes that he's a good man and that
he's done all these things for the
greater good and that hopefully all of
this will lead to humanity having its
faith restored in the superhero
community as a whole
you